Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast,
the file Monday morning podcast for 2012 Monday,
December 31st,
2012.
Um,
happy new year.
You know,
there's no new year's songs are there other than than that dumb when you sing
after they do the countdown,
right Ilene over with some chick who's got red wine breadth and fucking great
teeth.
Oh,
we could go up to your suite,
right?
That's how you bring in the new year.
We'll actually wrote a new year song for you guys this week.
This is what I do for my listeners.
All right,
here it is.
Um,
in the spirit of New Year's.
Here it is.
Happy New Year to you.
Am I going to get sued?
Happy New Year.
I'm never getting money off this right to you.
Happy.
No,
the new year too.
Oh fuck yourself.
Hey,
happy new year everybody to,
you know what the great thing about our New Year is?
Cause you just get to say fuck the last year.
Right?
And Act like because the sun's going down and coming up and it's a brand new
year that somehow you're a different person.
Somehow you've learned something from last year without even having to apply
yourself.
That's,
that's a big drunk talk.
New Year's Eve.
Dude,
I'm so glad this fucking year resolve it.
This year,
worst year ever fucking wife left me my kids shock.
I fucking cracked up my calf the other day.
Right?
Fucking good rate and stowed dude,
fuck this year.
Right when I love it.
It's the year.
It's not the decisions that Douche bag was making for the last 365 days.
Oh,
it's not that.
It's something about the year to this year.
Just doesn't like me.
You know,
like you're breaking up with this year in 2013 is going to be different.
Even though you're going to drink just as much.
You're going to hit on that Chicot work.
Right?
It's still going to smoke a whole fucking,
I dunno.
Sandwich bag of weed every night helps me sleep,
dude.
Right?
You keep telling yourself that lie.
You know
people,
if you want true change in your life,
I'm sorry,
what am I a guru?
I'm not.
All right.
Okay.
There's a nice fucking deep groove up to my neck of me doing the exact same shit
for the last 44 fucking years.
So who the hell?
Who the hell am I preach?
Um,
I'm just saying if somebody starts that shit with you tonight,
I do.
I'm so psyched.
This year's over.
This was the worst year.
Like did that,
that fucking philosophy.
That's the same philosophy is people who go a see,
there you go.
A bad things come in threes.
Bad things come in threes now.
They don't,
bad things happen.
Bad things happen every day.
The problem is,
the reason why your math works out is every time you get to three,
you just start back over and start saying,
now here's a new group of three.
You can say bad things happen in [inaudible] 17.
You fucking wait long enough.
Say,
there you go.
You know,
that's number 17.
Bad things happen to 17 morons.
They're not smart like me.
Um,
yesterday I actually played drums with a guitar player and a Bass player.
And a,
I realized something is that's just a completely different ballgame and I suck.
So fucking frustrating.
You know,
when you sit there playing drums by yourself for fucking ever,
you know,
and just sitting there thinking like,
you try it out,
all this difficult shit play [inaudible] no triplets in fucking five,
no groupings.
That just doesn't work.
All it does is make the people around you turn around and look at you like what
the fuck are you doing?
And um,
Oh God,
it was frustrating.
It was really frustrating and I've been playing a lot lately.
Um,
I dunno actually played with,
uh,
one of the guys I played with was Mark Marin and Mark Marin can fucking play
guitar,
but guy was,
he was killing it was fucking killing it.
So I got to step up my game.
I thought I was the best instrumentalists slash podcast host.
Okay.
Um,
and no,
there will be no tapes or video.
What are you think I'm an asshole.
I don't get trashed enough on Twitter.
You know what happened to me or not Twitter the other day?
No Bill,
how would we know?
What do you think?
That's how we build our lives around watching your fucking Twitter account are
right.
Relax.
I was a,
you know,
I'm not big on the social network networking things.
I don't like it.
I don't like talking to people and I,
I certainly don't like Twitter with this whole fucking like this sense of
entitlement.
People have that.
I have to go on there and be funny.
You know,
this fucking chick gave me shit.
I was sending links to a couple of funny videos that I saw,
you know,
and then I think I tweeted about upcoming show,
God forbid,
you know,
I do something like that and she wrote,
I wish I got fucking had him for me.
She basically wrote for the love of God,
write something funny in the box.
Hits,
sent.
No,
write something in the box,
hit send.
Don't forget to make it funny.
Thank you.
Right?
And Dude,
I swear to God,
I wanted to find this fucking cunt and just choke her to death to the brink of
death.
Okay.
Right before she was going to pass out and then ease up.
Let it get a nice fucking
okay.
Gulf of oxygen and then just blast or in the face.
And I know you were just thinking that's violence against women.
No it isn't.
It's violence against a woman.
Hypothetically.
All right,
so why don't you your group and your website's stand the fuck down.
That's what I wanted to do.
I didn't do it.
You know what are you going to get me for something I was thinking of doing like
that Tom Cruise movie.
Every time I see a brinks truck and I see the fucking guy coming out of the back
with the two bags of money and that guy's sitting there with his pistol is a
little pea shooter out of the holster.
Don't you always think that?
What am I just punched him in the face?
Give the other guy leg sweep and just grabbed those two bags.
How fast can you run with two bags of money?
Yeah.
You don't,
do you think they have a bank robber gym and that's one of the things you do and
they have some social personal trainer,
each one of these bags.
Okay,
well it's 25 bucks.
You are going to run with these bags up and down that hill because when it comes
to the day that you're going to rob a breaks truck,
you've got 8.5 seconds to get back to that little car.
Okay,
good.
Good leg starts.
Cramping up tight pipe.
Hi.
Not Talking.
Your leg starts cramping up.
You think the cops are going to give you a do over the hey,
you going to be in the fucking price and sale?
Yeah,
we're sore triceps in a butthole that won't quit.
Yeah.
Hey everybody.
I talked to the phone.
Get to 20.
You think that exists?
Um,
anyways,
so
I was uh,
so what do I do?
Usually I don't respond,
but this woman,
yeah,
so fucking pissed me off with her.
Chop Chop.
You work for me.
Fucking cunt hair attitude
that I actually wrote back.
I just wrote back,
I said,
I don't think I wrote back.
I quit your whining.
Yeah.
All right.
But somehow I erased her name,
so I sent that out to everybody who follows me on Twitter.
Quit your whining and then everybody starts trashing me,
says the guy who makes his living Wyman.
Right.
And then everybody's trashing me and I,
I just said,
I can't win for losing on this shit.
You know,
I'm not into this shit of getting heckled off hours.
I stand on a stage that's on me.
I was dumb enough to go up there and go,
hey,
everybody look at me.
You know,
I don't give a fuck them but this shit where I'm just sitting at home.
You know when somebody talks talking to me like that,
you fucking co where that,
you know,
you know what,
God help the fucking guy that ends up with that woman,
Jesus Christ.
What a fuck it,
you know what I mean?
But I swear to God,
that's how young people are right now.
You know,
they weren't raised right.
Like me and my generation,
we were raised right.
We had to pay for our music.
You know,
if you miss something on TV,
you fucking missed it and you are just stand there at the bus stop staring down
at your stride rites.
As everybody talked about the space,
1999 episode that you fucking miss last night,
feeling like an outsider,
you know,
not these fucking spoiled brats.
They just grabbed the little smart phones and they just fucking look it up and
they all watch it shaking their heads.
Ello elling and whatever the fuck it is they're doing.
So now here's this woman who doesn't fuck like she talks,
she's talking to me,
talking to me like,
like she's paying me some sort of salary on Twitter.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Something funny strikes me,
I will tweet it out,
but I want to give you a link to some woman diving off a cliff and knocking
herself unconscious.
I'll fucking do that.
All right.
Whew.
Jesus.
Dude,
I'm so glad.
Fucking 2012 is over.
I had the worst year ever on Twitter.
Um,
anyways,
and to everybody who's listening to this right now,
and then it's going to write the exact same thing on Twitter and think that
that,
that's somehow original.
Just know that another 500 people already fucking did that.
That's another fucking thing.
You know,
now that you guys have a voice,
the general public,
and you can insert yourself into being possibly whatever seen by millions of
people,
why didn't you try to be a little more creative after all your years of bitching
above fucking movies and saying,
oh my God,
how many times can they make that movie?
You wouldn't fucking believe the amount of times I write something on Twitter
and then like 30 people have the exact same clever angle
laughing their fucking asses off while rolling on the floor.
Evidently,
Oh,
I'm in a canteen mode.
So anyway,
let's get on with the podcast here.
I barely watched any football yesterday
cause I was too busy hacking away at a drum kit.
I played all right.
He's one of those deals where I played fine and I sounded good,
but I just thought I was so much fucking better.
Jesus.
Wasn't that a nice fucking ice bucket of water to the,
did they ego.
Um,
and you know,
it's really been bumming me out this whole fucking week.
I hate when people throw out their Christmas trees like the day after Christmas
or two days after Christmas.
Like,
oh thank God that's over.
It's like,
what were you just going through the fucking motions?
You know what I mean?
You just can't wait.
Okay.
It's quite,
the fucking body isn't even cold yet.
They throw out these trees,
the trees are still green,
you know what I mean?
It's laying on the side of the road with that shocked look on their face.
Like,
oh,
what I do,
the contract said through the new year,
you know,
I don't know.
Going back to what I was talking about last week about the whole NRA and getting
rid of guns in that type of thing.
And like,
remember I was saying like,
they should have some sort of like test to find out who the sociopath.
So that's kind of a red flag to me.
When you throw your Christmas tree out that quickly,
that means that you,
you don't have any,
you know,
you don't have any Christmas in your heart.
You know,
you don't get that warm fuzzy feeling around the holidays going,
you know what,
this is what's really important.
You know,
take a couple of weeks off from the fucking rat race.
You don't,
you're just sitting there with a sweater and a pipe in your mouth and your leg
up on the coffee table laughing at laughing.
When the other humans laugh,
they start laughing.
Then you ha ha
right.
Just going through the fucking motions,
you know,
probably got bodies in your basement.
Nobody knows because the fires fucking cracking and there's the Christmas tree
and then the second it's fucking over you close up shop.
I don't know,
it's just,
it's,
it's fucking creepy to me.
It's a combination of creepy and then I hate people don't dispose of their
Christmas trees properly.
All right.
You dispose of it like a body.
He cut that fucker up and you stick it in the green can.
That's what you do.
You don't just throw it out in the street,
you know,
let me just let society deal with it.
That's right.
I used the word society.
I don't think this cough is ever gonna go away.
Um,
overrated.
Inhaling mold.
Okay.
I actually have another scar that I still want to smoke.
That's how fucked up this is.
It's really bad.
Oh,
by the way,
uh,
my dog this week got sick.
I,
I dunno what happened.
She just started like I'm telling you,
if you were going to have a squirt gun,
fight with diarrhea,
like that didn't make sense with shit.
I know what I don't like.
It was,
you couldn't even pick it up.
Okay.
It was fucking crazy.
We woke up in the morning and she had shit all over the living room.
Poor thing.
She was whining in the night
and I didn't hear it.
Yeah.
And uh,
she was trying to let me know like,
dude,
something bad's about to happen.
Right.
And I didn't hear it.
And fucking woke up the next day with like a
lake eerie of shit on the hardwood floors.
Right.
So take her out and she just has the shits for like two days,
so we have to go bring her over to the vet.
Okay,
and by the way,
what's funny is she loves going to the vet.
If you walk into my house,
she will try and rip your head off.
But if you,
if you're at the vet,
because we boarded there a couple of times,
there's something about when she goes to a place where they,
she was taken care of.
Like she just loves you forever in anybody who walks in,
she loves them.
She fucking loves everybody at the vet.
She's got like that old school like blue collar loyalty,
you know?
Hey,
anything you need,
anything you'd a after what you did for me?
No,
seriously.
Seriously dude.
After what you did for me.
Okay.
Anything you fucking to look at me?
Anything you fucking need.
That's her vibe when she's over there.
Anybody walks through that fucking door.
Okay.
They're cool with you.
They're cool with me.
Then I called you,
you just say the fucking word.
That's her vibe.
She turns in,
she goes from this hell hound.
She comes like,
she's literally dragging me into the vet tail wagon,
comes in,
she puts her paws up on the front desk.
Everybody,
Hey Cleo,
how you doing?
You have kisses for everybody.
I don't know what happened.
She,
if she could just fucking be that way when people came over to my house,
it'd be the greatest thing ever.
So anyways,
we fucking go over there
and a whatever.
So now we got up,
we got to somehow make a eat this pill,
but we do is we just grind it up and we just sprinkle it on a food.
So if she's eating that stuff and uh,
you know the deal,
now I got to get some sort of fucking stool sample.
So they gave me this little thing like you'd keep weeding and those little
medicine bottles.
Okay.
Uh,
what's the fucking word?
Summarizing it really just fucking grossed me out.
I pick up the shit in the,
in the shit bag.
There was Rappaport would say,
and I just throw it in a barrel.
It's no big fucking deal.
But there was just something about carrying that and like I was keeping it is
just fucking gross.
So the Po and what kills me is I get the stool sample like fucking two days ago
and he is just like,
why did you do that?
I'm like,
I immediately go defensive and like,
cause a fucking doctor said to him,
so now walking around with a vial of shit,
my pocket,
you're giving me a rough time about it.
She goes,
whether or not open until Monday,
I go,
well what the f what do I do with this thing?
So actually on my front porch,
I've had a vile of shit
underneath my rocking chair
for like the last two days.
It's probably frozen solid.
And uh,
I don't know what I'm going to do.
You know what I mean?
I know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to hell.
I'm going to just tell Nisha to bring it over.
That's what I'm going to do.
If I'm going to pass off the fucking responsibility.
He also told me I need to start brushing your teeth.
So I've been doing that.
And I don't know if you've ever tried to brush your dog's teeth.
It's the funniest thing.
Like you'll laugh your ass off as it's happening unless you get frustrated
easily,
which I do,
but not with the animals.
You know,
you can't get frustrated with a dog that fucking hilarious.
So the second you start brushing their teeth,
their tongue,
they just start going.
So the whole time you're trying to brush their teeth and they can't stop.
It's like give a,
give a dog peanut butter and they sitting there fucking
whatever you call licking their chops for like the next 20 minutes.
That's what she's doing.
And I'm laughing my ass off and I can't get a fucking front teeth cause they're
stupid tongue keeps going like in and out and then it becomes like a,
that sounded disgusting,
didn't it?
Mold.
Okay.
MMM.
I really should get checked out,
shouldn't it?
Okay.
Yeah,
but that's not what guys do.
We don't get checked out.
Something bad happens.
You just fuck you push through it.
If it came up in athletics,
you know,
you just push through the fucking pig.
Okay.
That's why we die earlier.
You know,
I think my eyes are starting to go,
am I going to go to the doctor and go look and get some glasses?
How funny is that?
Even been making fucking nerve fun of nerds all this year and then my Karma is
now,
I might need glasses.
Could somebody please Photoshop some pictures of me with different glasses on?
I just want to see what I'm going to look like,
how bad the heckling is going to be because somebody said,
well why don't you just get contacts second.
I don't want to work context.
That's like having a toupee.
He said that fucking thing stuck to your head underneath your head's all sweaty
and shit.
Like I don't get people who were fucking toupees like why would you,
it's like having a hat on forever.
You know?
I always wondered about people who have to pays like at night.
Do they just take it off like,
oh,
just fucking sit there fucking scratching this skull.
The top of your head smells like hockey stuff.
I know it's gross.
This has been a gross podcasts,
but I'm just saying
I don't get the fucking to pay at all.
I don't get hair plugs cause they look horrific.
But they got this new way of doing it now where they vacuum the hair out of the
back of your head and then they just parrot troop it on to the top of your head.
And that's the first thing I've ever considered.
Okay.
Where I've just been like,
you know what?
When they do it that way,
it looks natural.
But then they sent me a video of the,
uh,
the actual procedure dude.
And it's like right out of silence of the lambs.
It,
there's so much fucking blood you wouldn't believe it.
This is just been disgusting.
This has just been shit,
blood violence against women.
And then there was a slight fucking beastiality thing is I'm talking about my
tongue,
a dog's tongue going in and out,
just the way I said that,
whatever,
whatever.
I'm just getting out all the bad stuff.
So two 2013 one did the three z can be the best fucking year ever for all of us.
You know,
that felt very cultish.
Um,
the fuck was I just talking about
the hell was I talking?
I said,
I can't even remember.
My brain just goes forward.
That's it.
It's gone.
It's over.
There's nothing we can do.
What happened?
Ah,
they just did just web Tommy.
Um,
anyway,
speaking of very cultish,
I was a,
I didn't watch any football yesterday,
so,
uh,
you know,
I didn't really have anything to talk about,
so I figured I would watch a little bit of news.
So I went to a,
the CNN one.
I figured I'd do that one next week.
I'll watch the Fox News just to keep it fair and balanced,
you know,
and uh,
they got this hilarious thing for Anderson Cooper.
They go,
Anderson Cooper is keeping them honest.
I didn't know what it means and he's got this fucking look on his face.
It's keeping who honest.
What does Anderson Cooper think he's doing with his little field trips over to
like different parts of the world with his bulletproof vest on and his hair is
still perfect.
God,
I'm jealous of his fucking hair.
I would take his full head of hair,
all white.
I would take it.
I would take that.
I would take just that and leave the sides red.
I do it.
I'd walk on stage looking like Jay Leno.
Fuck Steve Martin Right now,
right?
They both have grey hair.
Let's see.
Uh,
you,
you do the fucking math.
Anyways.
The fuck am I talking about here?
Did I lose this thought?
Oh yeah.
So Anderson Cooper's keeping them honest.
Right?
You gotta Watch,
I gotta send you the link to the fucking look on his goddamn face.
Like he really believes he's keeping people honest.
Who is he keeping honest?
Like he's invested,
let's say invest a major corporation.
Do they go,
Oh fuck Anderson Cooper's here.
I mean,
I don't know how tall the guy is.
He looks like one of those five foot eight guys with small hands.
It doesn't even look like that,
you know,
five,
eight little small hands.
So you know,
to make up for it,
God gives him a perfect head of hair.
You know,
had I been two inches smaller,
you know,
with the hands I had in sixth grade,
he would have let me keep my hair.
He would have you,
he wouldn't let me do it.
That's how it works.
It's in the fine print of having a soul.
Um,
so anyways,
they got Anderson Cooper there,
right?
And he evidently he's keeping keeping them honest.
That's about as vague as you can get.
Oh Damn.
Keeping them honest.
Don't lie to me.
That's like when,
what the fuck was it there?
Five hour energy.
He had the little pink bottles and then they said a portion of the proceeds goes
to fight breast cancer.
Well,
what percentage?
We don't deal in percentages.
Portion
cut you in a little slice.
Um,
so anyways,
so I'm watching this shit on the F FLDS church.
I have no idea what it is.
It's yet another group of people who had the audacity to start their own church
and have somebody that they listened to blindly,
you know,
and uh,
evidently they were predicting that the end of the world was coming
so they had their own grocery store in the center of town,
this little small town and they don't fuck they fucking closed.
They closed the grocery store doubt.
And then the authorities are going like the,
the report is going to the authorities,
the authorities going now is this a bad sign?
You think this is a bad sign?
And the guy's like,
yes,
we definitely think this is a bad sign.
We feel like it's suggesting that they feel the world is ending.
So there's no need to buy groceries anymore.
Sorry about the coughing guys.
Um,
first of all,
on two levels,
that story's fucking annoying.
First of all,
that you could be dumb enough to follow another fucking human being
that who's basically doing the ultimate dude.
I called it basically predicting,
not,
you know,
like what I'll predict that the Broncos,
and uh,
I was going to say the Greenbay packers,
but he was like,
what about Seattle's defense?
But I don't like their quarterback,
so I'm going to say the fucking Green Bay packers will somehow be able to score
enough fucking points against that amazing Seattle defense.
And it's the revenge factor.
Cause fuck the Seattle Seahawks and Pete Carroll
and he's not doing ric flair.
I just did ric flair.
He,
Carol's when they score a touchdown goes,
it's really long.
It's horrific.
So because they have one more victory in the ledger than they actually deserve.
I'm saying Greenbay goes in there,
whether it's in Seattle and they're artificially loud stadium,
you know,
with that 12th man,
the Douchey,
his thing and football,
the 12th band,
they need us,
you know,
they do everything but give their fans palm pumps anyways,
great fucking defense.
So fucking great defense by the way that they made the 40 niners with that
second year quarterback look like.
The 49 is what the second year quarterback,
unlike the Patriots'
Let some score 31 points.
Am I still fucking bummed about that?
Yes I am.
Although I saw some shit yesterday what their pass rush,
you know,
then maybe we're seeing the future that would really help out our corners.
Um,
so that's what I'd call.
So anyways,
back to this fucking church.
So you're dumb enough as an adult to follow another fucking person that says
they know what's going to happen.
But then what was bugging me too was this reporter,
he's walking around,
nobody wants to talk to him and he's sitting there harassing him and he's like,
the ladies were were polite,
you know,
unlike the men.
And it's like,
no,
you're sexually attracted to females.
See coming at them with the different vibe you came at.
The guy's like a cunt.
And then also with guys is always like that,
hey,
I'm going to punch you in the face vibe.
This guy sitting there talking about the difference between men and women,
like an 80s comic or something.
Wait,
did I just do it too before I trashed him for doing it?
I don't fucking know,
but this is the thing,
this sitting there going like,
you know,
watching what's going on with this church and I guess their leader is already in
jail.
I don't know what he did.
I have no fucking idea.
But I got to up big sense that a lot of it had that he had the audacity to start
his own fucking church.
Eventually you're just going to end in jail or they're going to burn you down
and then they go and brings up a conjures up images of Jim Jones and David
Koresh.
That's what I love about these things.
Why don't they ever bring up mainstream religion too?
Like my religion,
you know all the murder and crap in fucking child molestation and all the shit
that like my religion is horrific.
The inquisitions getting in bed with the Nazis.
I mean,
just write down,
if you go right down the most Judas moments in history,
there's going to be a rep from my church sitting right there with his little red
hat on.
Or maybe the big white one,
the big steeple hat.
I Dunno.
I don't understand why they just don't leave these fucking people alone.
Just leave him alone.
If people want to start a fucking church,
let him start a church.
And if they want to think some regular guy is Jesus,
let him.
And if he tells them all to go drink a bunch of poison,
let them
what?
What?
What are you saving?
You know what I mean?
And you know something like our compassion in the long run is going to kill us.
All right?
We're,
we're fucking overpopulated.
All right?
And because we're so good at Madison,
the fucking week survive.
If you're fucking dumb enough to drink a fucking glass or ripple or whatever the
fuck you drinking,
what,
because some guy told you that there's space ship coming.
Okay?
If you're fucking dumb enough to do that,
you shouldn't be here.
Let's say now I don't have a right to say you shouldn't be here,
but like it's,
it's good for the herd that you exit as soon as possible.
That's how I look at it.
You know,
polar ice caps are melting.
Everything's made out of corn.
Now,
would it really be that bad if a bunch of fucking people who are dressed like
Quakers,
following a guy who says he's the Messiah,
if he tells you to fucking kill yourself,
if they just killed themselves,
whether it be like you go in and then you save those people and then where do
they go?
What?
All of a sudden they're smart.
Do you send them through some sort of don't believe another human being the next
time they say that Jesus class,
they don't.
They just go in and save them and then they just let him out again to go out and
do the same shit all over again.
I've just let it,
it's like bankers Yak,
like you're fucking outraged and then what do you do?
You get in the fucking houses back.
None of them go to jail.
They get the houses back again.
To do the same bullshit all over again.
So you know what it is.
People without reading,
without even being remotely intelligent,
I have the whole world figured out.
You got to match.
As much as I've been preaching on this podcast,
I,
I do realize
I'm going to cop myself.
I'm going to compliment myself for realizing that I'm a Douche.
Jesus Christ.
What's with my ego today?
You know what it is.
I need a boost after embarrassing myself or just not playing well yesterday on
drums.
Like literally like in my head,
I was to the point that if ever when like if I ever got called to do a fucking
drum and Gig that I could actually pull it off.
Like that's where my fucking ego was.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
let's get on with the advertising for this week.
Everybody.
We got some quickies here,
uh,
over the holidays.
Um,
amazon.com everybody if you'd like to support this podcast,
um,
I gotta do is go to bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and then there's a link over to the right for Amazon.
Click on that brings you right to Amazon.
Everything's the exact same price,
but if you buy something after he goes through my website,
percentage of the proceeds,
they kicked me something,
right?
And then I fucking kick a portion of that to a,
for the wounded warriors project.
It's been a great thing and I want to thank everybody for doing it this entire
year and last year it's been awesome.
And,
uh,
is there one other one?
I'm the fucking worst.
I never know.
amazon.com was there one other one?
I think I don't give a shit.
Okay.
Was there one?
It's the holidays.
What are you going to do anyways?
Let's plow ahead here.
Um,
what else did I want to talk about?
Oh,
I actually got a feeling that,
uh,
now that the Broncos have home field advantage,
dude,
they're looking like that.
They could possibly do it.
Okay.
You know,
I was hoping the giants were going to make the,
uh,
the playoffs because,
um,
I had this,
this football fantasy,
not fantasy football.
It's a football fantasy.
All right?
So don't get a fucking twisted.
I had this football fantasy that,
uh,
the Patriots somehow with their defense win the championship this year and Brady
beats both manning brothers.
He Beats Peyton like he always does.
And then he beats fucking Eli for the first time,
even though he fucking should have beat him last year.
You have fucking model.
Sorry.
Um,
yeah,
but the giants didn't make the playoffs,
so what are you going to fucking do?
You know,
what are you gonna do it?
But I,
I don't,
um,
I dunno.
I liked the Gronk is back,
but I don't like our,
uh,
I just don't like our fucking defense,
you know?
I still think we're at least a year or two away.
I've said it every fucking week.
And uh,
you know,
when you play that fucking game,
we're going to score 35 points before you do.
It just doesn't work in January.
There you go.
I've said my piece and speaking of Boston Sports,
I'm really getting into the Celtics now.
This is how much I like punishment,
like right as is,
they're tapering down as they're spiraling down.
I actually,
um,
okay.
You know what it is.
I like the building of the castle,
not standing back looking at it like I like watching the Celtics right now cause
I like trying to figure out what their problem is.
And as far as I can tell is we have absolutely no defensive presence.
Nobody's afraid to go to the rack.
We got nobody.
You know,
Garnette has fought enough wars for the love of God.
Can you get the guy some help?
We got absolutely spanked by the fucking clippers the other night.
I watched that whole God damn game.
I know a lot of people shut it off or whatever,
but uh,
I'm really glad I didn't go to that game cause that would have been it really
annoying.
MMM.
To listen to all those La fans fucking trash in the South Dixon and I would know
that,
well I can't say that they're right because they would just be going,
you know,
Celtics are bitches and that type.
They wouldn't be like breaking down the game,
but that's not what they do out here.
They just say your bitches and then,
you know,
I don't know what three people stomp on a father with his,
with his two kids there.
That's what,
that's what La fans though.
So what they do,
but for some reason Philly fans keeps getting respect,
like they're the craziest people ever.
Um,
anyways,
but like I was just watching that game and I was our record at that point.
I became like 14 and 14 and I was like,
that is the exact record that we should be because we are a middle of the pack
team.
And um,
I dunno,
went up to
golden state last I saw I was what was working that night.
We were down by like 17.
It's a rough road trip for us,
but um,
I'm going to enjoy watching us try and put it back together and Danny Ainge did
at one time.
I'm hoping he can do it again and uh,
it's going to be fucking brutal.
But as long as the,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
as long as the Lakers don't win it,
I think I'm good.
I'm actually slowly becoming a Knicks fan because they're on TV all the fucking
time.
So that Jr Smith Watch the replay of that game,
hit those two ridiculous shots,
one to win it.
And I can't remember who the fuck they beat cause I'm so not an NBA fan.
But um,
Nick's can't beat the bulls though
so far.
They can't.
All right.
I'm in,
I'm in way over my head.
I'm just starting to watch it because evidently thinks will be no fucking hockey
this year.
You know,
I got this great tradition out every year when the Bruins come to town and they
play the kings,
I go there with a bunch of buddies of mine.
We just have a great time and an la king fans are cool.
They're great fence.
They're not decks or whatever,
you know.
And I don't go there wearing all my Boston shit,
just trying to be an obnoxious asset share on the Bruins or whatever.
But I'm not a cunt.
I would go there and congratulate the kings fans on their championship because
of know they're good people.
I don't have a problem with them.
Okay.
Um,
so anyway,
so let's,
let's get on with some,
um,
some fucking questions for the week here.
Uh,
Bill Finland,
uh,
get your show to Finland asap.
Could use some gloves here in this freezing country.
Sincerely,
all the fins.
You know what sir?
Normally I would trash you for acting as though you speak for your entire
country,
but,
uh,
the fact that you're inviting me saying that everybody there wants to go.
I'll take that.
I'll take that nice fucking blow to the ego in a good way.
Um,
I'm actually,
uh,
I came up with a great idea for how I'm going to tour that part of the world,
um,
next year and I'm going to run it by my agent on that.
Literally on the second I got a great idea of great promotional way that I'm
going to try and fucking do that.
And um,
I definitely want to come over there again without a fucking doubt because I
went to Anderson Cooper who was keeping everybody honest and I realize why I
don't fucking watch the news.
It was just,
it's a,
what do we got here?
Here's some sort of the top fucking stories,
but bus skids down in Bankman kills nine
so I put that on and it was a bunch of people on a bus coming back from Las
Vegas going all the way up to Vancouver.
You know what I mean?
And that's one of those things right there where I just,
you just makes you not believe in a God,
you know?
Or maybe God was like they've had enough,
but it's like,
isn't it enough?
Yeah,
that you know,
you're obviously man,
what the fuck kind of money you make.
And if you got to take a bus from Vancouver all the way down to fucking Vegas,
right?
You didn't win enough money to buy a fucking ticket to fly back.
You get back on the God damn bus just sitting there.
Hundred bottles of beer on the lawn or bottles of beer going all the way fucking
back with maybe with a bucket full of quarters that you wanted some slots isn't
that enough?
You got to slide down a fucking embankment.
And that's the thing.
It killed nine people.
They don't talk about all the other people.
Probably had injuries that they're,
you know,
lifelong going to be nagging them.
It's just brutal.
They had that.
They had the guy who said he's Jesus
dying.
Mom's youtube.
Goodbye.
Right?
I didn't even watch that one.
Five-Year-Old finds porn on Christmas gifts.
Dad Delivers Breech baby on side of road.
They go,
they always give you one to fucking,
you know,
for every 10 horrific ones,
listen to pilot explained stuck in the mud.
I had to watch that one.
Some southwest pilot was taxiing to go off to go take off and he just fucking
drove off the runway and that now the FAA is going to investigate what happened.
Isn't it obvious what happened?
He was texting,
you know who hasn't done that?
He was texting.
It's too early in the flight to talk your way into a fucking hand job.
You know?
That's the only other thing that could be distracting you to that point.
How does that happen?
He played patty cake with the fucking copilot.
I want to hear that black box.
I bet the the engineer does it still three people up there.
When I was a kid,
there was this one guy back,
they would just turn some knobs because the other guys just sat there with their
mustaches waiting to take off.
Did that other guy who turns the knobs as they're sitting there playing,
you know
Eddie and Johnny sit near a tree when they were fucking doing that shit.
Is that a patty cake song?
I Dunno.
Um,
that's gotta be on the black box.
Whatever song they were singing,
whatever the fuck they were talking about.
And then the guy in the background,
guys,
guys.
And then they go into the mud.
Oh,
maybe it was the guy who sits behind
guys,
here's my impression.
This is fucking Michael Jackson meets and they're turning around and looking at
it.
Is there anything more pathetic than the wheels on a plane?
You know what I mean?
You ever see like when somebody buys like a fucking brand new pickup,
but they get the most,
the bare bones version and they basically have like the pocius looking tires you
ever,
they can't even fill up the wheel.
Well,
you literally can see that the coils in the side of the engine,
the tires,
so fucking small,
there's nothing more like that.
Then then the wheels on a plane,
they're just sad and pathetic.
And I always wondered why they didn't get bigger rims.
Uh,
wait a minute,
am I talking about a soul plane?
Right.
You know what?
I think they had that right.
Some nerds actually probably gonna write him actually though.
The weight of the rooms would actually,
you fuck the other vector?
Is that the right word?
Um,
all right,
let's get back to here.
Finland.
I'm definitely coming over there.
Hopefully in the next year.
My calendar is filling up.
I'm just waiting for the links so I can tell you guys where I'm coming.
I guess it wouldn't harm if I could tell you guys what cities I'm going to,
would you like a teaser?
Um,
here's the deal.
I can tell you some that I'm definitely going to be at right now.
All right.
I'm going to be at flappers comedy club in Burbank,
California on January 10th.
I'm going to be at the republic in Hawaii.
Honolulu,
Hawaii on January 26th I'm going to be at the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts.
February 21st and 22nd I can't give you dates here,
but just to perk your ears up in case you hear your city,
this is like school cancellations.
[inaudible] back in the day when you're waiting to hear your town and for all
use all they use who don't live in a state or a part of the world.
Whereas school would get cancelled because of snow.
We used to listen to it on the radio,
right,
okay.
Are or watch the news or something like that.
And there would be like the following schools have been canceled,
Dota,
whatever,
Snow fall and they will be like Winthrop north Redding,
Redding.
You'd just be sitting there,
fall river,
just waiting for your s,
you know,
and then they,
they get to whatever,
whatever your town began with,
whatever letter and you just fucking sitting there.
It was the greatest thing ever.
No school because of snow.
You didn't have to fake sick or anything.
So anyways,
here we go.
Here's the list of cities so far.
Then I'm going to be at starting in March.
I don't,
I can't give you,
I guess I can give you dates.
Uh,
March 7th through the ninth,
I'll be in Madison,
Wisconsin,
Milwaukee,
Wisconsin in grand rapids,
Michigan.
March 22nd 23rd,
I'll be in Indianapolis and then Minneapolis
and April I'll be in Atlanta,
Tallahassee,
Miami Beach,
Austin,
Texas,
Dallas and Kansas City.
I haven't been there forever in VA and a May.
I'll be in Las Vegas at the Mirage Red Bank,
New Jersey,
Baltimore,
Maryland,
eastern,
wherever the fuck that is.
Atlantic city's that all jersey.
Uh,
I'll be in Chicago in June also in Pittsburgh.
I'm going to be a bunch of places.
Hyannis Hampton,
Newport,
this is July Montreal.
Foxwoods in August
in November,
Philly,
New York City and Washington DC.
If your city was not called then you have school.
Um,
and that,
that's it so far.
So somewhere in there.
I'm going fucking slam a European trip in there and now it's all going to be
good.
But back to the podcast,
everybody,
sorry.
I feel like the funny hasn't been coming here for a few minutes.
Let me see if I get back to it.
All right.
Self deprecating bill.
Hey Bill.
I can't keep from hating myself.
I have like obsessive self hatred and no matter what I accomplished,
some dark part of my brain is always going to shit on it.
Uh,
you think some insecurity would help push me to better myself,
but this is too such a to such a severe degree.
I can hardly function because of the resulting anxiety and stress.
I have a feeling you can relate to an amount of this.
Yeah.
He really went out on a limb there,
especially since you're also a musician and shit on your playing ability as much
as I do mine.
And was hoping you could offer some advice in how you try to remain positive if
you fucking even do thanks.
Merry Christmas.
Um,
all right.
Merry Christmas to help.
We had a good Christmas.
Um,
well you've actually,
I think you've,
you've,
you've gone over the toughest hurdle so far.
One of the,
one of the hardest hurdles.
The first one is actually addressing
that.
You know,
that you do that.
One of the hardest things to do is to stand outside yourself and sort of watch
your thoughts and watch how your brain is functioning rather than just thinking
a thought,
taking it as law and then letting your body go into a state of anxiety and
stress and all this stuff that you're talking about.
Um,
what I try to do to try to stave off those demons is I just,
I just try to,
mmm.
Just analyze my thought process when I'm starting to think negative and
everything.
I just kind of just almost take like a timeout and just literally be like,
okay,
now if I actually
like take that that thought is law.
Like how is that going to make me feel and how is that going to help me this
day?
Whatever this day is.
December 31st,
2012 is only going to happen once.
Is it going to be another one in the shit column?
Or I can make it positive and then I just try and,
I don't know,
go to the gym,
go play drums,
do something fucking positive,
try new joke or something like that.
But what I,
I try not to do is fucking,
I dunno,
just let that thought grabbed me by the neck and just pull me down to the bottom
of the lagoon.
It's really like a choice,
unless she has,
I guess,
some sort of clinical depression where it's literally like a chemical at which
point I'm in way over my head and you should go see a doctor.
So I would,
um,
okay.
I Dunno.
Did your parents suck where they assholes where they always shitting on
everything you did or maybe they loved you,
but like they had a,
they had a fearful way of looking at the world and they always came up with
something negative.
It's something like that,
but at some point you got to go,
you kind of got gotta turn the bus around.
MMM.
I mean that,
that would just be my advice.
That's kind of how kind of,
how it works for me.
But,
um,
okay.
I Dunno,
I feel like in the middle of the night I have my most negative thoughts and I'm
just fucking tossing and turning or part of it.
And,
um,
Nia told me last night said,
you okay?
She worked.
We have goes,
are you okay?
And I said,
yeah,
why?
Okay.
She goes,
you were moaning,
moaning,
like moaning to me is like,
like sexual.
And she's like,
no,
not like that.
Like you were in pain.
So I dunno,
but then when I wake up,
I always,
I dunno,
I,
I'm always in a positive mood when I wake up,
you know,
cause I wake up with next to my girl,
I see her and then I see my dog.
My dog wants to go out and I,
so I started off in a real positive thing,
but there's something at night,
my demons come out at night.
I don't know what it is.
I have like fucked up dreams.
I always have dreams where I'm beating the shit out of the person,
but I can't fucking get them to like,
just stay down.
They just keep getting up or I'm throwing punches really fucking slow and they
have a knife and they get to try and kill me,
but they can't,
they can't quite kill me and I can't quite knock 'em out.
MMM.
I don't know.
And I don't know what any of that fucking means.
And I went to therapy and all that shit.
And uh,
after a while I just,
you know,
I was just like,
you can't shine shit.
What?
I'm just wasting my money here.
Jesus,
that was brutal site.
Um,
all right,
bill,
I hope that helps you a little bit.
Uh,
I would read books about positive thought.
I'd go to therapy.
I would,
I would literally attack your depression like you had it.
Like somebody who has a weight problem,
starts going on a treadmill and starts eating.
Right.
I would literally,
rather than just sitting there filling the hopelessness of it,
I go on the attack and um,
yeah,
I really hope you turn it around do because life doesn't give a fuck.
It sucks.
Like it doesn't care if you have a bad life.
It's,
it's all on you.
You got to come up with a game plan and that can be overwhelming.
But like,
just,
you know,
the whole fucking cliched one day at a time,
but life doesn't give a fuck if you don't get the girl.
It doesn't give a fuck if you become homeless.
It's,
it's not,
you know,
that whole Guardian Angel Horse Shit that this little Tinkerbell on your
shoulder trying to guide you.
It's bullshit.
It's,
it's,
it's on you.
I know that that can be overwhelming,
but it's,
it's a powerful way of looking at your life.
Like you have the control to make it good or bad,
you know?
And I'll be selling my books on tape.
Uh,
dental billion.
I recently,
I recently watched a talk show appearance.
You posted on your Twitter you mentioned?
Yeah,
I did the,
uh,
the Willie Hunter show.
MMM.
And I think that that's what I posted when that fucking Twat that I'd like to
choke to death with a garden hose sent me that tweet.
Um,
yeah,
it was on the Willie Hunter show.
And he said,
you mentioned you were a dental assistant.
MMM.
For your father.
Did you ever consider becoming a dentist?
Did you ever,
did your father ever have ambitions for you to become anything in particular?
Um,
no.
My Dad,
my parents were great.
Like they,
they wanted you to base,
they didn't force anything on you.
It was like whatever you wanted to do.
MMM.
They supported it 100% and I remember being working with my dad and in the
dental office when I told him that I was going to become a comedian,
we were in like the break room and I remember I was sitting there like going
like,
how is this guy going to take this when he has such a classic,
okay,
like stable job here.
You know that I'm going to tell him that I'm going to fucking
basically make a living,
try to make a living doing exactly what he's been yelling at me for for the last
fucking 20 years of my life,
which was fucking off and acting like an idiot and screwing around all the shit
that you know,
when he would give me Christ,
check that box you're in a town clown do you would be giving me shit,
which I totally deserve because if you ever saw the grades I got in school,
I mean they,
they,
they are,
they are horrific.
Fucking horrific.
The high water mark for me was like a c minus or a c like I was,
it was brutal.
Okay.
I went to it had to go to summer school every fucking year of high school except
my sophomore year.
Yeah.
Because my math teacher hooked me up in my senior year.
I should have gone.
I just didn't give a fuck.
I was like,
what's the point?
You know what I mean?
That's like you got the ball with 10 seconds left and you,
what are you going to do?
You just fucking,
you know,
you're down by 30.
Yeah.
Just throw up a half court shot.
Did it go in?
Who gives a fuck?
It doesn't matter,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
so no,
I mean for half a second.
You know what,
you know what I did like,
I like the,
uh,
I like the pouring up models.
When I was in a,
when I was in the dental office,
that was my favorite thing.
I was in the back,
I was isolated.
I wasn't around anybody and it tapped into that little kid thing of playing in
mud
and he used to pour up the models and they had this vibrating thing and you had
to tap on it to make sure you've got all the bubbles out.
And I prided myself on not yet
being able,
you know,
of having it without no having no bubbles.
So if you've got bubbles,
if there was bubbles on the bottom,
basically,
you know when they stick that pink shit in your mouth and they got to take a,
an impression of your teeth,
then somebody's got to take that out of your mouth going in the back room and
then you got it.
You got to mix this powder with water up in those little green rubber balls.
Jesus,
this is all coming back to me.
And then you poured it into the fucking impression you took and then there was
this,
this thing that sounded exactly like your cell phone vibrating on a table and
you just,
you just tapped it on that to get all the air bubbles out of it.
And if you didn't do it enough after one of the things set and you took it out,
um,
if the bubbles were at the bottom,
that's where the teeth were the most crucial thing,
the exact fucking thing that trying to get a gauge on so they can,
you know,
whatever the hell they were trying to do,
make a bridge or something.
Um,
the whole thing would be fucked.
And then you couldn't go and just rapport the model into that same mold because
somehow like it had shrunk up a little bit and it wouldn't be accurate.
And my dad used to flip out.
He would,
he would take them off and be like,
Christ,
there's bubbles,
you know?
And it was beyond your boss yelling at you.
It was also my dad.
So I already had,
you know,
I was going through my fucking teenage and early twenties when you're rebelling
the most against your fire.
Already had the live with the guy and then I was working with the most fucking
hilarious and he used to give me shit like,
you know,
like I was his kid,
but we really have,
we actually talked about how we had to tone that shit down because it didn't
come off as professional in front of patients,
so whatever.
But um,
but that was the part I thought if I ever got into dentistry that I would,
I would,
I would work in the lab.
I liked that part of it,
like,
um,
and not just pouring up the models like the actual,
I know there was a precision to it that I liked.
I didn't like to fight.
I didn't like the,
uh,
the front line shit going in the mouth with all that crap and looked at people's
fucking horrific teeth,
just horrible fucking teeth.
All my jokes were about that shit when I first started.
I told you guys that story,
right?
I used to work totally clean when I first started stand up.
Um,
and not because I wanted to be this comedy purist.
I just was afraid of offending somebody in the crowd,
getting heckled,
not having a comeback,
losing my place in my act and then bombing horrifically.
Yeah.
And,
and just having my career end,
total fear,
catastrophizing,
like way of looking at it.
And um,
yeah.
Oh Jesus Christ.
That really just fucking brought me back to,
I was standing on stage at stick stitches.
Fucking somebody heckled me was that the vault and Boston.
So we had called me and I completely lost my fucking train of thought
and I had nothing and I didn't.
And it took me like basically three seconds to,
to,
to re to remember what the fuck I was talking about.
And um,
it was the longest 30 seconds in my life and I didn't know enough to just say to
the crowd like,
what the fuck was I talking about?
Because they'll tell you,
they'll remember it.
They're not nervous,
they're listening.
They,
they're not having like this outer body experience.
Uh,
but anyways,
I remember people would come into the dental office and their teeth would just
be just,
just what an absolute fucking mess.
And they can tell you right now,
I hate coming to the dentist.
It's like,
yeah dude,
I can smell it.
You don't have to smile.
I can tell you don't like coming to dentist.
You only like fucking brushing your teeth.
Okay.
Oh,
just one guy said this,
one of the first jokes I did.
Oh,
that's right.
So I would work totally fucking clean.
And then my last at my,
and you just,
you know,
when I looked like a young Ron Howard,
I look like Richie Cunningham and I was totally clean and I was clever and I had
these perfect talk show monologue jokes and everyone was gone like,
oh dude,
you're going to do the tonight show and this is going to be
perfect than Blahblahblahblahblah.
And then the last joke in my act,
I quoted this patient who kept having to get fillings and root canals and he,
and he said,
doc,
you know,
I don't understand what's going on.
I mean,
I brushed my teeth almost every day.
And then my,
my snappy comeback to that,
that I thought of that later became the last joke of my act.
I said,
really deal,
wipe your ass almost every time you take a shit.
And that's what I would close with after working totally clean.
I would say that disgusting lie.
Do you wipe your ass almost every time you take a shit?
Having everybody in the crowd after looking at this fucking Norman Rockwell come
to life,
fucking character wholesome is hell right.
And I really was back then as opposed to the piece of shit that I am now after
20 years on the road that I became,
um,
okay.
And I literally,
they had to conjure up pictures of somebody skipping,
wiping their ass and just that hold and they would
just literally recoil.
Then I would just be like,
you know,
thanks a lot.
Good night everybody.
You were great.
And um,
okay.
I had another horrible one that I did,
uh,
were,
I actually brought a prop on stage and if you'd like to see that,
I tell the story,
the
Willie Hunter show and a willys an up and coming comic at the comedy store.
And he's the guy who threw the Hula Hoop,
took the hula hoop from that girl in.
Fucking threw it into the street.
I tell that story too.
If you want to see that shit,
check out his shell.
I tweeted about it.
Anyway,
so let's plow ahead here.
Winding down here on the podcast.
Um,
fight question bill.
So we in this kid decided that we would have a little boxing match.
That's funny.
How,
how quickly before that went from the,
the,
the parameters that you guys said.
All right.
No real hidden here.
Just kind of body shots.
How quickly before it turned into just complete anger.
Anyways,
he said he didn't know that I hated him.
Ah,
dude,
you're evil.
You're a fucking evil dude.
So mean.
This kid decided that we'd have a little boxing match.
He didn't know that I hated him.
Fuck you dude.
You want it to beat the shit out of this kid.
You talked him into it.
Just the fact that you said a little boxing match and you're trying to like tone
down.
You and this kid decided that you would have a boxing match,
a little boxing match.
He didn't know that I hated him,
so I was determined to rock his fucking dome.
Okay.
But we start fighting and he's kicking the shit out of me.
That's hilarious.
He goes,
I finally hit him right in his temple and his fat ass gets knocked the fuck out.
Okay.
Um,
about a week later he found out that he broke his hand on my face.
So he tells all the bitches that he actually won because he broke because he
broke his hand and couldn't punch that hard after he broke it.
Does that sound like bullshit to you?
MMM.
I don't know.
It kind of seems like you guys all,
you both got what you deserved.
You fucking hated them.
So you wanted to fight them.
Evidently he's a Douche.
MMM.
So he got knocked out and his hand got broken.
He fucked you up a little bit.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
now he's walking around bragging about it.
But yeah,
it is bullshit.
It is bullshit.
You won that fight.
You knocked him out.
You took what?
You took his fucking punches,
you know,
and then,
uh,
I just really like I was being an asshole there.
You weren't asking me if either one of you guys was the bigger con.
You're just asking who won the fight.
You definitely won the fight.
He definitely won the fight and he's fat.
So you went in on two different levels.
So you,
as far as I see you,
when you got two belts,
you got the,
uh,
the fighting of the boxing belts and you got the,
I'm in better shape than you,
so congratulations.
You know what she could do?
You could fight him again,
although you would be risking losing,
cause it sounded like he was getting the best deal in the beginning.
But
you know,
why don't you guys do that?
Why don't you have your fucking,
your trilogy,
maybe he wins the next one.
Then you have the rubber match and then you put it on local cable access.
Paper view,
right?
You pet your charge a little bit of money.
No,
you charge tickets.
This is what you do.
You got to become friends with that fat Douche.
All right,
and you do just,
what boxes do you pretend?
You know,
like you have this animosity,
like you don't have this deal.
Like there's not a big fucking,
I mean you,
you really do have the animosity but,
but there's a bunch of money
at stake.
So he talk a bunch of fucking Shit,
right?
So more people show up to the next one.
All right,
and you take a dive and the next one you let the fat fuck beat Ya.
So now,
yeah,
everybody's choosing and you say that he cheated and you say fuck you.
And then you say,
I'd beat you the first time.
And he says,
fuck you.
I broke my hand.
I could have one.
You build up to all this big fucking hissy fit.
Then you have the rubber match and all of you guys know that this one's real and
you charge everybody a dollar.
You fucking have it at the local rec place.
Do you guys even have rec rooms anymore?
You're too busy on your fucking smart phones playing video games.
It says,
is there a place where you hang out?
Then you got that kid in your grade who already has a mustache.
He buys booze for everybody,
right?
You charge money for the booze.
Maybe that's what you do.
Somehow you make a little bit of money out of it and then Al for the rest of the
time,
when you go back to your high school reunion,
it's going to be this awesome thing that you did this fucking entertainment.
You know,
you might be slurring a little bit,
but I think that would be great to have your own fucking Thrilla in Manila.
Just my 2 cents.
All right,
here we go.
Hire a ref.
Maybe one of your friends works at Athlete's foot,
so you already has the fucking shirt.
You know?
See what I'm saying?
There's a whole wonderful world out there of entertainment.
If you guys get your faces out of your smartphone,
go back to do what we did when we were kids.
You didn't virtually punched somebody in the head.
You did it for real.
Um,
you know,
I,
I got to go to a doctor.
I can't even laugh without coughing anymore.
Sound like a fucking minor.
All right?
Soon to be brother-in-law Douche.
Okay.
Here's the situation.
My wife has an older sister and she's been dating the same guy for nearly 20
years now.
Okay.
I was literally thinking about something else,
so I don't even know what I just said.
I got to reread this.
Okay.
Here's the situation.
My wife as an oldest sister,
and she's been dating the same guy for nearly 20 years.
All right.
My wife has only eight,
was only eight years old when this guy started to come around the house.
So naturally she becomes close to him because she was always,
she was always hanging around her sister and this guy is over for the next few
years.
Okay,
I get it.
Um,
let's jump ahead now to where I come into the picture.
When I start dating my wife,
we hung out with her sister and her fiance at the time a bunch of times,
but this guy is a know it all and a materialistic prick.
So I quickly knew me and this guy would never hang out other than at family
functions and get togethers,
which is totally fine.
That's totally fine.
You got a good head on your shoulders.
That's exactly it.
All I gotta do is smile and wave with some eggnog in my hand once a fucking
year,
maybe at a birthday or maybe a cookout and then that's it.
Um,
and I suggest not getting drunk at those events because a,
your real thoughts will probably come out,
at least in the car ride home when you sit in the,
I can drive,
I could drive and then it's going to be all of that shit.
Whatever.
I didn't want to go anyways because he's a fucking digging.
You're gonna have that whole thing.
Anyways,
here we go.
After a few years of dating,
we buy a house in or about to get married.
Okay,
Bill,
sorry for the boring shit so far.
But here's,
here's where the story starts.
Now it comes a time where you have to pick people to be in your wedding party.
I have three brothers and thrill,
real three real close friends that I would consider brothers and I could only
pick five because that's the number that we had that we came to make things even
out.
We are not rich,
so we couldn't afford a giant wedding.
So it's pretty obvious that I have the slots filled and still have one close
person left up.
We're here.
Comes to part with a douchebag.
Sister's boyfriend.
Yeah.
Boyfriends because they called off the wedding four years ago and got back
together.
Just recently engaged again this Christmas.
Um,
she makes a giant stink about not being,
oh,
he makes a giant what
this is.
The other guy makes a giant stink about not being asked to be the best man.
Yeah,
I said the best man.
this guy's a dick.
This fucking cunt really expects me to,
to put him as my best man at my wedding.
I'd never even hung out with this moron in like four years.
And like I've mentioned,
these spots were already filled with friends being left out anyways.
Oh,
other people feel like they've been left on anyways,
while his side of the story is that he treated my wife like a sister even better
than his own sister,
and he felt that my wife should have included him until the wedding party.
Now to be fair to my wife,
dude,
I don't need to read the rest of this fucking goes on forever by the way.
It's like another to listen.
Okay.
It's your wedding out of a courtesy to you.
I guess I got to read some of this.
I think this has to be a reason why this was sent to me and it's his fucking
long.
Do you guys want to hear the rest of it?
Come on.
You probably have stewed.
You want to hear the rest of this feed out?
Click off.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Well the hell was I.
I'm not to be fair to my wife,
she did tell me what he wanted her to do and she knew it wasn't going to happen.
So obviously he was not going to be in the wedding party.
Instead,
we asked for him to be an usher.
That's hilarious.
Is standing in the back of the church,
stupid,
whatever the fuck you call it.
When you're that guy that helps the old ladies to their seats and whatnot.
Dude,
I think that's even funnier than not having a minute.
Um,
so anyways,
well,
not only did he decline,
he also refused to go to the wedding entirely.
Yeah.
What a fucking bitch.
You know what?
He's got that Colby gene.
Unless he's scoring 30 he doesn't want to be a part of it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Anyways,
I didn't give a fuck because the guy is to a conversation with a smelly yogurt
gushing.
Okay.
All right.
I didn't want it.
I didn't want anyone in my family or any of my friends.
Never know this guy exists.
Okay.
So basically you're like awesome wedding.
Now I won't get into all the stupid shit this guy did over the next year,
but he started a bunch of bullshit in the family,
including two particular phone calls to my wife in which he spent two hours
screaming and belittling my wife about him not being in the way.
This guy's crazy mixed with a whole lot of other held in frustrations this guy
had.
If you ever wonder,
wondering what my wife's sister does about all this,
the answer is nothing.
She's a jellyfish,
standing idly by or man,
sad motherfuckers.
But anyways,
I was cool planning on never seeing this asshole again,
except maybe at the inevitable funeral or something like that,
so,
well,
he just popped the question again to the jellyfish.
They're get.
Yeah.
He probably asked her to get married just so he could not invite you.
He goes,
now this is the ball flicker of this email people.
I'm in the last paragraph,
by the way.
Yeah.
The word is,
he's going to ask me to be his best man.
Oh,
you went the other?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Dude.
You realize this psycho is probably getting married to this woman.
He doesn't even love.
He asked her.
He,
Oh my God,
this guy is a fucking sociopath.
Okay,
wow.
Wow.
Just to rub it in my wife's face like he's the better person assumption,
dude.
Turn him down.
Just you.
You got to clear the fucking air.
Be like,
dude,
I don't,
you're not my best man because I don't like you.
Anyway.
He goes,
it's bad enough that I wanted to capitate this dude already for the Shitty said
to my wife,
but how the fuck am I going to handle it when he asked me to be his best man?
Obviously I'm not going to do it,
but I'm just wondering how you would tell him to fuck himself in such a way that
then it will bother him,
deepen his brain to the point where he can't sleep at night because of how badly
he was pumped.
This guy thinks his shit don't stink already,
so it's not as simple as,
no,
I won't be a best man and go fuck yourself.
He would win in my eyes if that happened.
I need some heavy duty ammo for this fucking flaming narcissist.
All right,
dude,
this guy is drawing you in to a trap.
Yeah.
All right.
He's drawn you into a trap.
Have you ever told your wife to be that you don't like the guy?
Just say,
listen,
I respect the fact that what he is to you,
but I just don't get along with the guy.
Okay,
and I,
it's in,
it's your wedding.
You have the right to pick the best man and the fact that the guy throws a
fucking hissy fit that he's not the best man is beyond psychotic.
It's beyond psychotic behavior.
Okay,
and and just tell your wife that the reason why you're declining to be his best
man is because you feel that it's not coming from the heart.
He's actually using a major portion of his wedding as a way to try to get even
like tit for tat and try to make you look like a bad guy do this guy's just a
complete cycle.
All right?
You love this girl.
You want to get married to her.
You guys have the right to pick who you want to pick and everybody should honor
that.
And the fact that this guy not only cannot handle it,
he's been calling up in screaming
at,
at your wife rather than you,
rather than being a man.
I would just ask the guy to go out and have a drink
and just sit the guy down and just say,
listen,
you've been screaming at my wife for the last year.
Okay.
That alone,
I don't want to be your best man.
I don't want to be your best man
because you yell at my wife.
That's why for me to be your best man would then be like me saying it's okay for
you to yell at my wife.
Okay?
You shouldn't have asked me to be your best man,
which you should have done is you should be a man and go apologize to my wife.
I,
I would.
I would go some route like that,
but the worst thing that you can do is get drawn into this thing where now
you're trying to come at this guy like,
oh,
he's going to try and get me.
I'm going to try and get him.
This guy's going to win because he's drawn you into this fucking trans guys out
of his fucking mind.
You guys have a wedding.
You picked your best man.
He couldn't handle it.
He screamed at your wife.
That didn't work.
So now he's getting married and now he's asking you to be his best man.
I don't even think you talked to the guy.
Just talk to your wife.
Just be,
listen,
I don't know what this guy's deal is,
but he's,
he's,
he's freaking me out.
This guy freaks me out.
I don't know what his deal is.
Okay.
I have a right to pick my best man.
I did.
Um,
this guy should have been a gentleman and it accepted it.
Instead,
he called up and berated you numerous times for a couple hours on the phone.
I wanted to say something to him,
but I didn't want to disrupt the family.
I was a gentlemen and now he's asking me to be his best man in to,
to just decline them.
Just say,
no,
I don't.
I,
I don't want to do it.
Just leave it at that and then let him pow.
Just let that guy keep pouting,
but don't get drawn into the emotion of it and then think that you have to have
an epic.
No.
Just say no.
I don't want to do it.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Hour and 14 minutes.
This is the longest fucking podcast ever.
Um,
all right.
That's a podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Happy New Year.
Um,
2013.
It's going to be better than ever if you make an effort,
if you make an effort to,
if I'm not even getting into this fucking horse shit,
I don't even believe it myself.
All right?
You are who you are fucking accepted and fucking settle in for another year of
this bullshit.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll try to get the mold out of my goddamn system by next week.
All right.
Oh,
rose bowls tomorrow,
so please do not sleep on next week's podcast.
We're going all out once again,
and we have to try and top the previous fucking four years.
Four years.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.